[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 42 of
GameSpot after dark game sports official
video game podcast
I'm your host Jake Decker and joining me
this week is Lucy James hello callie
plaguey hi
and tomorrow saying hello that how are
you all doing good no let me out let me
out we've had a fair share of technical
difficulties getting this going but we
are here and we are now going alright
it's been it's been like a week of tech
difficulties but you know what
just thankful that oh no it's fixable
it's not the end of the world mm-hmm
well I might be close to the end of the
world but like botfly fights anyway
that's weird start podcast Wow yeah
absolutely
don't don't only brought it down by
talking about the saying that we are we
might be close to the end of the world
but in a way anyway let's talk about
video games Kelly how's that stamp rally
going it's going um I've seen a lot of
people talking about how the stamp rally
is boring and stupid in Animal Crossing
yeah I was gonna say we should clarify
Animal Crossing stamp rally started in
Monday yes for International Museum day
and like with the other events in New
Horizons they span more than just the
day um I like the stamp rally like like
it's definitely for kids right it's not
like a super involved event I thought
made a was really clever cuz made a was
like a puzzle that you could solve the
stamp rally for International Museum Day
is just going through the exhibits and
collecting stands but it is very
Japanese it reminds me so much of doing
touristy things in Japan and like I
tweeted that like when I was in Japan
last year at the Tokyo Skytree there was
this like special bar being
of it and there were stamps there was
like a stamp thing and stamp stations
for the Barbie exhibit we've lost him
no just keep going if that happens I
think it's discord not me anything on my
end
okay just froze for a second but yeah so
I I thought it was like a cute way to
celebrate International Museum day and
get you to go through your museum if you
had int in a while and I had it and I
was able to go through and be like okay
there's two fossils I'm missing oh I
didn't realize I put fish in that tank
I like the last time I was in here there
were no fish in that tank so I I thought
it was a cute cute little bit I mean not
every event has to be bunny day where it
takes over your whole life so yeah I
want to check it out I haven't done it
yet I've been hard at work playing other
things currently but it seems it seems
neat like it seems like a fun little
thing to do especially like I feel like
people are still playing Animal Crossing
anyway and it seems just like a nice
diversion to head in there check things
out maybe learn a thing or two in my
video games now I feel bad because I
guess the other tweets of I but I fully
fallen off Animal Crossing now um I
think it's because I'm spending so much
time playing persona it's like you get
one game to donate all my time to I'm
not very good at going between two but I
like the I'm still people making
incredible things in it and bringing it
and I enjoy seeing them on my timeline
and videos and stuff but like I didn't
even know Museum day was going on cuz
I'm just been I'm just out of it now
yeah I feel like Museum day probably
isn't enough to bring people back in and
to be honest like I'm kind of like you
right now I'm playing a JRPG so I don't
really have time to play Animal Crossing
but I am kind of waiting for the next
big update I guess yeah yeah I mean the
prizes aren't super exciting but the the
nice thing is you can get multiple
because the stamp stations change every
day so like I could collect multiple
like gives them to friends who weren't
playing whatever but I mean I don't know
I I played new leaf every day for like a
year and a half and I played I played
wild world every day for at least two
years so I really like Hamill pressing
it as part of my lifestyle yeah so I
will just continue I will continue to
play Animal Crossing every single day
and check the store and check my turnip
prices and do all of that stuff and it
is hard because there are other games
that I know I just want to play but need
to play so but I you know and putting a
lot of time into terraforming now how
about you tomorrow it sounds like you're
doing some exercise
yeah I was kind of like I put a ring fit
in there but I just want to say that
game is ingenious like it's every time I
play I'm like this is a unbelievable
application of gaming into exercise it's
so good it's the best they've any I
think anyone has ever melted those two
things together so I played a bit of
that I downloaded AC origins because
Jordan from our editorial team tweeted
that you could get some DLC the curse of
the Pharaoh's tomb or something like
that and it basically makes you makes
your hidden blade and headshots with
arrows one hit kills which is how I
prefer to play that guy like the old
hidden blade way you'd insta kill so I
was like all right I'm gonna do that I
haven't actually started doing that
honestly I'm mostly playing persona like
I'm playing I'm 55 hours 60 hours into
it now that's my main thing that I'm
currently playing and I'm really loving
it but I also kind of want to get
through it so I can stop my Yakuza
replay which I'm very excited for I
started by dipping into your kisses 0
from the middle again I thought you know
I'm just gonna start all over again and
do the entire series so that's my plan
and I'm watching Jake play blood-borne
Jake and Matt project that's my main
form of gaming now yeah mostly Matt
playing but I've been playing alongside
him just to see what's ahead of him but
he he's about to face off against the
final boss but I I guess I'll just
transition what I've been doing but I
finally did old hunters DLC which I got
right when it came out I played
blood-borne a ton when it came out which
I think I've said on the podcast but for
some reason I just never went back for
old hunters finally did it and man am i
mad at myself I waited this long cuz it
is good some of the I think some of my
favorite bosses in the game are in that
DLC the only one I don't like which I
don't think is surprising like I don't
really think you're supposed to like the
boss named the living failures which is
a great name but like all of them were
so good
I I was super stoked because I beat the
final boss I almost beat him my first
try the orphan of costs yeah which I
mean that was kind of a fluke cuz I must
be to my first try and then he kicked my
ass a couple times but I think that's
generally how it's supposed to go like
I've my first time we've often of course
I almost beat and I was like oh and then
just a turns on it turns on and it's
like oh okay
you were just lulling me into a false
sense of security but it's that that is
probably well I don't want to I don't
want to say who the middle how far are
you into it Lucy was there was a lot
boss you for I think it was Ludwig okay
the boss after that which I won't ruin
in the in the town I know who is okay
yeah it's the lady yeah lady Maria the
lady Maria boss fight is like one of my
favorites in that whole game and it's
basically the foundation for Sakura like
that yeah game is that was them figuring
out Sakura in that DLC I definitely got
that impression fighting her it's like
oh this is this is a second row boss
like I need to get ready to to block
encounter yeah but I'm just dodging so I
love about from software games like if
you pay attention to the game that
you're playing made by them you can
probably find the seed of the next game
in there and for me the one that I think
that has been the seed for the next game
coming is castle cainhurst and Elden
ring I think those two are going to be
connected
where it's this far off you know area
that you go into that feels completely
different from the rest of the game and
is almost like stylistically distinct I
think that's gonna be what olden ring is
where you're just going from Kingdom to
Kingdom and getting these mythical
artifacts to do this one thing but
everyone's gonna feel different like
want to feel like Sakura 103 like dark
so I don't know feel like blood-borne
yeah I wonder if not to get too
off-topic here but I wonder if they'll
kind of incorporate the play styles of
Dark Souls Sakura and blood-borne into
like building your class because like
Dark Souls definitely lean pretty heavy
into what kind of class you want to do
and even blood-borne did that to some
extent but then Sakura was very much
like this is how you're gonna play this
game but I'm curious if Elden ring will
kind of embrace these different styles
in terms of what class you decide to
play if that's even a thing or if
they're just gonna go down like this is
how you should be playing this game
which I don't think based on that teaser
and the rumors what is it what's the
what was the big rumor from last year
but the horses oh yeah yeah riding
horses I know I'd love to ride around
that world on Ludwig the horse orange
really wanting to finish I want to go
back to it yes she did to the last thing
I did was blazing bull and I had a bad
time I suppose a rough but I've been
I've been watching this it's not
Japanese but I've been watching a Korean
show on Netflix and it's a the same
around the same time period as sec
heroes when it's set so I've been I've
been itching to play like a historical
game it's called Kingdom and it's like
in Korean take on Western zombie fiction
a little but I don't really like the
zombie stuff they're kind of like fast
zombies and I'm kind of like man fast
zombies they're like 28 days later
zombies but um the political intrigue in
the Joseon era Korea was is really
interesting what are you watching on
where
it's on Netflix oh oh because I remember
starting it but that was in the UK so
out and I feel yeah
so yeah did you ever watch Empress's in
the palace Chinese historical drama that
took like a month me Sarah who used to
work in our UK office and I became
obsessed with Empress's in the palace
because it's basically just like
historical [ __ ] what that I'm very
into but I never finished it because but
like it's very good for a while it's all
about concubines and yeah speaking of
historical [ __ ] and concubines you
should definitely watch the handmaiden I
have I saw that good so I saw that in
the UK they do a thing called secret
cinema where you basically it's an
interactive theatre thing and there are
loads of actors and actresses and for
the handmaiden one you have to dress up
and it's all themed all the guests
you're not allowed to speak mm-hmm so
you you sat down and had dinner together
and everyone just had to bring your pad
of paper and was completely silent then
they show the film and then they reenact
some of the scenes and they reenacted
some of the scenes I saw some nude
people on our stage it's very good
anyway that that movies really good but
I know exactly the scene you're talking
about
yikes which I did not expect to see
that's very good foreign cinema break I
mean if you want to segue into what I've
been doing it actually kind of flows
very well I've been watching historical
[ __ ] I'm watching the great my mom
wanted to watch that she's watch oh good
did you watch the favorite mm-hmm yes
it's one of the it's the guy who
co-wrote the favorite and it's all about
Catherine the Great is there less vomit
and in the show but in the favorite
episode for you're not gonna have a good
time okay there's one episode miss
picturing like people from that era but
it's that scene from Family Guy where
everyone drinks that yeah Africa and
this is vomiting but I saw like people
dressed in royal outfits
so what the favorite felt like to me I
still liked it though it's very very
good very funny
nicholas hoult it plays pizza the
Emperor and Alfa Nicholas Hoult
of that zombie movie theme oh my god I
forgot he was in that one use it I was
gonna say about Hank McCoy Hank McCoy
and Elle Fanning plays Catherine she's
incredible and then I made myself sad
because she's only 22 and I was like how
she this like she's so good in it her
comedic timing is perfect but she also
has the poise and grace of sort of like
an aristocrat and I was oh my god she's
trying to her skin is also unbelievable
but yeah it's very funny and it's like
even though it's set in Russia it's
really British like they throw the
c-word around all the time which is a
Brit concubine what's it on Hulu
so it's who over here I don't know if or
how the UK is gonna get it probably
iPlayer maybe I hope so it's really good
I've been devouring it and I very much
recommend that you watch it avatar la
semaine de is now on Netflix yes
central viewing for if you are a human
on earth you need to watch that show the
best TV show ever made I love it so much
do you want to tell them about our
unfortunate it's like conversation about
avatar oh my god I think you should tell
them because you're the problem with it
very earnestly like no one you really
want to wreck you know when you know
someone's gonna love something and you
just what you want them to like to just
receive your earnest the recommendation
properly because you're like I know this
person I know for a fact that they're
gonna watch this and they're gonna it's
gonna change their life I think I love
it so I I sent loose your message and
that's what the story begins I'm trying
to find it I wanted to see it if it is
as bad as I remember because I just like
completely shat on your dreams yeah
um but but yeah avatar came out on
Netflix today you should check it out
smart media response with site mate this
is a quiet humble place and then I went
oh the anime I thought you meant the
2009 James Cameron you probably murdered
some more by calling it literally said
Christ
my heart broke it's true that's how my
mum replies to things shy shite pet it's
a perfect show and I think no I'm not
even a perfect it's a perfect thing like
creation a perfect creation a better
thing could not have been created in
like the thing about it that I always
say to people who haven't watched it is
like the first season you're you're
gonna be all like a little more
Nickelodeon like there's a little more
kid stuff in it but God I'd like a show
that ends so beautifully too
it's one of the few endings that I've
finished and I was like that was perfect
it couldn't have been any better like
its Legend of Korra by the Abbott ah
people yes yeah I just know he's in the
core but I think it's because I was so
attached to avatar that I just yeah
I watched avatar I don't remember a lot
of it I should probably watch it again
now that someone clicks but I did meet
the voice actor for Zuko and I had no
idea did not click until much later it's
like through someone who helps out
during e3 she was having a movie showing
and I went to I went to go see it and he
was there and I started talking to him
he's like oh yeah I'm Dante is Dante
Basco
and and I didn't even click because he
who's the producer on her film and then
Dante box
yeah and then and then and then I left
and Michael started talking about him I
was like and why does that name sound
familiar I'm like oh I met him that's
why and then I looked it up and I was
like so it's probably good that I didn't
know who he was cuz then it would've
been like oh my god I've seen this but
instead I was just like hey how you
doing I think I had like drank some
whiskey with him or something like that
and then just moved on I like that joke
it's not anime though
anyway should we start shooting people
under the topics alright call of duty
black ops cold war
I
ooop tab is gone how much he feels about
core G so what it's liek that that's the
locale I guess I mean so let's just
while we're waiting for Tam to come back
on the surface the title black ops cold
war like to me I'm like the point of the
Cold War is that there weren't like are
we doing are we doing espionage we
didn't stealth like what I imagine it'll
be cuz black ops 1 a lot of that took
place like in around the Cold War so I
imagine it'll be something similar yeah
okay like I'm curious if it's gonna be
like a full-on reboot sort of like
modern warfare but then why would you
feel the need to call it cold war I
don't know it yet strange strange by the
way they just put in videos like is
discord down oh cool well you being like
yes you're doing cut in half on the
video really tough yeah you're like what
is down in right in after dark
holy cow what an interesting episode
should we keep going let's is just one
of many technical difficulties seriously
let me just message time and be like
well rejoin if you can
keep keep talking about something I'm
gonna resent tear your camera Lucy okay
oh no you are just cut in half we're
gonna leave it as is because I'm not
gonna be able to fix it on the fly well
no I can fix it on the fly I can do this
I can do this
so black ops I actually played a lot of
black ops 3 multiplayer for some reason
why I still don't know why it was I
would come home and play like a couple
matches every night so I mean one was my
big one because I was a uni and also
unemployed and also had three contact
hours at university a week so I very
very quickly prestiged in black ops I'm
sure we cross paddies in black ops
because I played a lot of black ops 2
yeah black ops 1 - yeah not - didn't
play one Wow oh my - yeah well I guess
now we've got Call of Duty Colin Black
Ops : cold war I don't know if there's a
second : I just put it in there to make
a joke about yeah games with with all
those fancy sub titles subheaders or the
it's fine no I was thinking of spongebob
squarepants
battle for bikini bottom rehydrated or
whatever because the full hold on I'm
gonna get the full title again because
it's really complicated and it pisses me
off it makes my life hard spongebob
squarepants : battle for bikini bottom -
rehydrated what was the Harry Potter one
was it it was like Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 1 the official
video game or something and it was only
a similar situation where I was like
there's too much grandma in there and
then like for my head like the way
headlines work is only so many words
like so many characters in the headline
actually make it into the URL and so
like you get funky URLs when game names
are that long and it makes things
difficult
I did see the engineers rolled out an
update about that today though I did
that wiki that weekly winds email mostly
good good for you guys cuz I didn't even
know that was an issue but I'm glad it's
fixed um that's the best kind of issue
one that you don't know as an issue
until Authority like why you're
brilliant you both spot it and fix the
problem
before I even knew it was there so
before we just to bring it back to black
ops cold war I don't know do you guys
have any like it hopes for it do you
want it to be like a kind of like what
they did with modern warfare 4 black ops
or doing something completely different
like I mean honestly black ops in that
new engine yeah I can see into it like I
think black ops storyline wise was Pony
my favorite just did it it was a really
weird mashup I think the story died in
that game was great
also with I won the Trenton and Atticus
did the score for if you like to think
so I do that one or two is what they
were for but that one has a bunch of or
that that original one had a bunch of
like top build actors right like Sam
Worthington who I don't know what he's
doing anymore but Gary all right after
to Union have you seen the video of Gary
Oldman on a talk show and he's on there
to talk about call of duty no he doesn't
know what it is I think he gets his
character name wrong but let's rain fire
you know do you ever have those little
kind of like a sound board in your mind
yes like that tick tocks
one of mine for example in the morning
is I go get my coffee and every time I
come back into my room I go meaning time
but it's the exact cadence of the woman
in Futurama who feeds little heads in
the head Museum and she goes fading time
so that's the kind of [ __ ] that I'm
working with
but rectifier it's one that is always in
my head
always
had it just always have this little
thing of Gary Oldman screaming rain fire
in my head
2020 I am somewhat you you put that into
words though because I have so many of
those and like we have like family ones
like my like my family will do them and
I'm like no one else knows what the hell
we're saying yep
uh he has their own little like um like
weird things that they call things like
a compound yeah poor [ __ ] like my
stepmom is called Judy but for some
reason we call it Judy bugs I've no idea
where bugs came from we've just done it
for almost two years
thank you my a big thing in my family is
from chicken run when one of the chicken
says are those the only choices whenever
we're presented with two kind of [ __ ]
options for something we all go mothers
the only choices you know you just never
know but anyway I was definitely more of
a modern warfare person and a black ops
person I I just was at a weird time in
my life with black ops 3 I guess but
like um I I'm kind of burnt out on
Khalid it honestly I wish that Call of
Duty would fully commit to the things
that it's trying to do like I even felt
that way in black ops 3 like that
storyline is almost about PTSD and then
like it it just becomes like surreal and
weird and I'm like oh like you all like
you almost got there almost did it and I
think like there there is a large
population of college of you players
that are veterans and I think that
that's something that would be good to
address in the game if like you're there
for the story so I don't know I'm
curious
i I do like yeah I wonder if veterans
would even want it to go that in-depth
though you know because I feel like a
lot of veterans just plain old you know
I I don't want to generalize but I
imagine maybe you wouldn't want it to be
too vivid but then it's weird because
modern warfare was like we're gonna be
super realistic
I think like the more I mean even for
what the sound design is way more
realistic yeah so I I don't know I don't
know I just know that my my to be fully
like I'm just gonna lay it out there my
therapist works with the veterans a lot
but she will she's talked about like how
like all of her veteran patients play
call of duty
oh really yeah cause it's like she'll
ask me about what I do for work and
stuff video you know like Pokemon call
it Call of Duty like you know the big
video game she was like oh yeah I love
my veteran clients I wonder I don't mean
I wonder if it's a kind of exposure
therapy in a way maybe my dad used to be
in a clan like back in the probably like
mw3 era uh that was just like all
Marines and then my dad I don't know
haven't happened but that's Xbox Live
for you yeah so I I think I don't know I
really I feel strongly about the
original modern warfare like I think
that like really pushed games of that
genre in a way that they hadn't been
pushed before um I love the original
monde warfare even for all it's like
quirks and I would love to see holiday
Felix stick to something a little bit
better maybe yeah one interesting thing
so race' Vic I don't know if you guys
have heard of him but he's a youtuber he
did a video about Call of Duty it's
really good I highly recommend it but he
did a video where he basically went
through all of the Call of Duty games
and figured out like what is the gimmick
this game and like if you look at them
they have this very interesting like
kind of predictable strategy where they
will do something to death until people
hate it and they want something else and
then they'll switch it up and they'll be
like look see we're listening this is
like this cool new thing that people
have been wanting
and then they'll do that to death until
people will get mad and then they'll go
back to the old thing and pretend like
it's new so like an example of that
right would be something infinite
warfare was the one where people were
like really mad and we're like we're
tired as we don't want futuristic so
then they went back to World War Two and
they were like look see boots on the
ground like that's what people want in
Call of Duty and I'm willing to bet like
we're gonna have a couple more Call of
Duty games and then people are gonna be
like all right well now like I want to
see that Call of Duty and future or I
want and it's just like this cycle that
doesn't really end of just like just
like right right when a mechanic or key
system is everyone's tired of it they'll
retire it and they'll just leave it on
the shelf and wait until it's time to
bring it back yeah I mean maybe I'm
asking too much of call of duty because
Call of Duty is really like an
entertainment product not like it's not
trying to be a statement I mean it is
kind of like a look I don't know if you
guys have that article about the US Army
recruiting people through college any
tournaments um so there's that I mean I
always find it weird when they're like
III and games come yeah with army so
there's that aspect of Call of Duty
which like we don't have to get into but
like I think the reason I bring up like
I wish colleges you would stick to that
the statement is because I think they
get like halfway there I would also love
to see like a really fun loving like not
grit not super gritty
Call of Duty you know also so like it's
not that Call of Duty has to be really
hard-hitting and talk about PTSD it's
just that I think they get like halfway
or you in three-quarters of the way
there and then pull back but but also
like Call of Duty is more than just like
one person's vision like it is an
entertainment monster it doesn't be a
myth it is theirs I mean some of the
stuff is just pure marketing like like
what Jake talked about like changing
changing the mechanics up that's a
marketing tool rather than like a game
design tool so I think ecology is what
it is and you kind of I felt that way
with modern warfare also I don't want to
see for temor but I know
like he and I had different
interpretations of that game and there's
so much I could have talked about but
it's like I can't really I can't really
like dig into like the entire world
around Call of Duty when reviewing it
so I feel in psychology you're super
complicated but I am interested to see
where they go next like I always am yeah
I think I've kind of hit the point like
i-i-i I guess I've done a similar thing
where I was in the coal dude and I burnt
out and like I didn't play or get
interested into a lot of them and then I
oh alright
why am I the only one that gets booted
out window server I don't know we kept
going we've been going for the past 20
minutes or so more what are your
thoughts well I just correlate discord
racist it's so insane
well I get the overlay fixed tomorrow
what are your thoughts on call of duty
black ops cold war whatever in it I'm
glad they're going back to black ops
they always did interesting story stuff
for black ops and so I'm hoping that
they do more of that again and not to
say that that actually I was gonna say
Modern Warfare story it wasn't good but
like 100 first story has a Fisher of
issues but I like the kind of like
attempt to do it I wish I wish people
would just this is the stiix place you'd
say I'm gonna pull back on that one the
army recruits people to your call of
duty so you're probably not gonna be too
spicy I mean the thing I was gonna say
is I'm sick of people pussyfooting
around controversial and political
subject matter or like twisting it into
some sort of news story if you're going
to tell the story about you know cults
in Far Cry tell the story about cults in
Far Cry if your crimes in the Middle
East
don't tell the story yeah make own own
the [ __ ] in the history that you're
claiming on the history that you're
using as a mocking be like put it in
your store
yeah and I mean obviously like that's
why I'm kind of a little trepidatious
about watchdogs Legion yeah it's
ridiculous then and I don't know how we
got here but like black ops has always
done interesting things with story and
if they can do a kind of like the
numbers Masons Thor thing within the
Cold War I'm all for it but if they're
like are we're gonna do a cold war story
that's politically charged and then just
do some like half-assed half-baked
version of a cold war story not
interested in that but they also do like
cool things just gameplay and you know
like the kind of like and they have
interesting for I'm excited to see how
it feeds into Wars on more than anything
because the because the rumor is that
it's going to be announced through
warzone instead of like a major you know
Cup warzone event and like to be doing a
fortnight thing of like yeah yeah let's
get a concert going - that would make
our last hard copy in the gulag let's go
also I just want to say that today's my
dad's birthday and he took the day off
to play brothers birthday - what's he
doing it's also my brother's birthday
you take you has a class well flex for
your dad to have a kid on his birthday I
know right well for your parents
anyway we've spent a lot of time talking
about Call of Duty but we should
probably move on to a new story that
broke what earlier this week Sony is set
to announce PS 5 game line up very soon
entire story yeah that's right yeah I
think the interesting thing is what do
you think is gonna be there right yeah
not born - don't cuz you're just gonna
get yourself excited so sad yeah even
more of a wreck than usual
hey we've we've updated blood-borne for
ps5 it's the same thing
I would absolutely take that yeah 60
frames decent framerate yay
that blew point game should be there Oh
what do you think it is either either
the new what the rumor is they're making
a new game but they also believed to be
working on the demon souls remake so
beloved yeah my first demon souls oh my
god I'm gonna get wet for sweat we were
really pushing the boundaries I'm
talking about overheating and stuff I
mean Joe cooks band name from last week
was a line which it would you sense it
or once but not that we don't believe
the second time like that we're gonna
see grant Therese now eight seven listen
I'm not reroute but it's like the white
bread of racing games isn't she
I haven't played since I was a kid
honestly like well I feel like four it's
that kind of just showed him up yeah
like if I'm gonna play a racing game
home and play for that and if I'm gonna
play a raising a racing game he'll is
probably frozen over because yeah I was
gonna say like I really that was a joke
I can't speak to before it's a org Gran
Turismo I have a planar racing game that
was a Mario Kart and it's like an 34
like a [ __ ] horizon yeah what's the
horizon this one just drive around in I
think the Gran Turismo games are really
like people really love them and they do
a specific thing but I think more and
more as the time goes on that series
feels more and more out of place with
the walls around it like they just still
doing like very straight-up simulation
track racing with like here's a foxhole
vector that you can race then you're
like why why would you do that
Top Gear built a whole TV show about
that exact concept so yeah true and then
I look at them Top Gear showed up in
Forza 4 instead of green trees
and it's just yeah III think I'm one of
those people
relax a little more like flavor and
spice in their racing games to get me
involved yeah I mean you guys I imagine
- if it's gonna be a launch title like
this is just speculation but I imagine
there's gonna be a lot of stuff that
have been in previous ones that aren't
gonna be in this and people are gonna be
surprised and disappointed by that even
if they are fans because I feel like
that that I mean that HAP that happens
with launch titles normally especially
like racing games I remember forts of
five or six which everyone's the launch
one for the Xbox one was like it was one
of the few games so I bought it and I
was like I'm just gonna play for it so
for if I want to play this cuz there's
way more and forth before and the top
gear guys are in there telling me about
cars conscient producers Romans Paul
from James May he's out like helping
like we've conquered belief is that
driving around and helping people out
where is Jeremy Clarkson who knows
anyway any other predictions we've got
Demon Souls smell horizon - I'm
expecting like souped-up versions of the
games that are bridging the generation
gap so allows us to go Tsushima what was
that one that was at the game was it God
God fall yes confirmed for peace but we
haven't heard anything about it not the
gearbox one yeah yeah okay I saw I mean
if you're listening to audio version you
will not be able to catch two more
slight eyebrow raise that what I'm
saying is no I don't know what you're
gonna say but don't that's where it
comes on and is just unleashed all these
spicy taste no say it's borderline
straight when the worst written games
I've ever played my lifetime just say
hey I'm Kings for it
well anyone I know you people do people
like it it's just it's just not for me
it's not me and that's fine
yeah and that's okay in my life it's not
for me
but it's fine it's fine it's not right
but it's okay but all the ancient name
references yeah well you I speaking of
dreams will be there and then there's
like a bunch of like crossover
generation stuff like like yeah like
games the service stuff like seed you'll
probably pop up in some regard like 14
confirmed destiny overwatch will
probably have some sort of presence I
hope I mean I wonder if they'll bring
overwatch and just leave it or just
leave it for - that would be weird like
I don't know if they're gonna do
cross-gen service that's one thing
because like that's not been a thing for
a lot of generations right I think maybe
Microsoft did it in some degree but like
ps3 - ps4 there wasn't like backwards
generational compatibility and for
voyage which is putting people from both
games in the same pool that's gonna work
mm-hm yeah I forget how destiny one did
it cuz that was cross generational yeah
I don't I don't think you shared it's
like with 360 owners and Xbox ones to
share I think you just like moved you're
saved and odine you have to go on PC to
do it use it now yeah once a once they
opened it up for like crossing across
platforms when you had to do that but
that would mean that overwatch would
need to be on the next generation of
consoles provided that it haven't
figured out some sort of cross
generational server solution I bet you
with all these although all these like
consoles and games talking to each other
but there's gonna be a way for certain
games to like like overwatch I'd be
surprised if you wouldn't be able to
play with people on PS 5 on your ps4 I
don't know maybe not actually I don't
know complicated but anyway we should
talk about ghosts as ghosts of Tsushima
not ghosts of Tsushima do you know that
we've been pronouncing it wrong I
realize in the last Tsushima yeah yeah
yeah things are it's like if you
pronounce it to correctly you sound like
a man so like that's my as well for now
at the american islands way that's
precisely what i've been doing like i
don't want to be that person is going hi
it's the transition from like normal
western speaking to like one word is
intensely japanese and then back we're
talking about ghosts of Tsushima I think
I've said this on the podcast before but
I have my friends and I in high school
we were taking Spanish classes and we
were joking about people like that and
the example was always hi my name is
Rachel I'm from who I so that's how I'm
always I'm very self Conte to sound like
that do wanna be Rachel from I don't
want to be Rachel from why so yeah I'm
fine with saying Tsushima it's fine
that's like me whenever I go to like to
get a curry how in public I'll be like
speaking and then like when I have to
say the thing of you know the I am I one
I switched to like Punjabi and everyone
goes yeah it's just this is how I said
it growing up so I haven't made that
like a point I'm not doing that for any
other language that direct was cool I am
very much into that game I you know I
really like is that the interact button
is on r2 and I was like like genuinely a
small thing that I noticed interact with
stuff Action Button was on r2 and I was
like yes that is economically pleasing
to me you came over fantastic tweet
during that but you never tweeted out I
was a coward you were a coward I was a
coward it was it was very good a lot of
my tweets I send two more for sort of
like he's my barometer for and as many
years as a me I'm that too Jake yeah and
I was gonna tweet broke hold f to pay
respects woke hold are to to pay
respects I had it ready to go and this
waited too long if this I liked it thank
you
good well one thing that I noticed they
actually called out as I liked how the
wind guides you the areas I thought that
was pretty near so I I had an interview
with Nate Fox his creative director on
Ghost of Tsushima which the interview is
up now on GameSpot calm final website
you can read it and there will be a
video version of it coming up on the
YouTube channel but we talked about a
bunch of things and one of the things
was the wind thing and I think I liked
about the conversation I had was at what
the question I asked him was like how do
you avoid being Assassin's Creed and
filling a map with icons that overwhelm
people is this the wind kind of thing an
attempt to do that and it was like yeah
kind of but the wind is there to guide
you to your Waypoint that you select and
your main missions but we've designed
the game in a way that we want you to
get distracted as much as possible
because we've put stuff out in the world
that isn't immediately visible you know
how Assassin's Creed is like every like
signposting or any interesting thing
exists in the world but it's also like
oriented towards you so you can see it
in a very specific way yeah so it's like
if someone's saying something to someone
they're like mouthing it towards you to
be like hey wouldn't it be good if
someone would help us with this issue
we're having they don't want to do that
they want to make it like seem like oh
there's something happening over there
like there's a fire stack that seems to
be or like there's some commotion
happening over there and you go there
and if you choose to go there there's
something there it's kind of like
there's a little indie game that came
out on PC and Xbox right chorim no it's
kind of like that develop a ragtag group
of people in poland you might have heard
of it but like that kind of thing where
you kind of it feels more natural when
you go there you have something
meaningful so the wind is kind of a
guide but also the interesting thing
about the wind is like they paid a lot
of attention into where they represent
nature in the game Fox
yeah you can pet the Fox not not the
creative director of the game Nate Fox
mr. Fox in the game I mean if you can
pet Nate Fox as well but fair play go
for it might find a bit weird yeah ask
him first secret permission find his
boundaries and then but they really
respect nature and they want to respect
nature in the game and the reason they
want to do that because the game is
influenced by you know summarize cinema
and the kind of symbiosis between the
aesthetics symbiosis between like a
wandering Samurai and the desolate
nature of nature if you get one saying
like you always have the samurai
standing in the field and like the grass
is blowing and like the trees the leaves
are like crossing over you know it's
very aesthetically pleasing and they
they're making sure that they're
respecting that as well
so that's part of it and the other thing
that I found really interesting was like
there's loads of Kurosawa thing like he
did it he did like a broke walk galaxy
brain thing as well where he was like
broke everyone guy in this game is
inspired by a key of course I was you
know work but actually the walk thing is
it's actually inspired by a comic book
series called soggy Yojimbo which is
like a really old is like really started
really long time going the A's and it's
still ongoing but it's it's a it's like
a world of anthropomorphic animals you
know standing in for humans and it's
about this rabbit Ronin who's just like
his sake means rabbit in Japanese but
he's like a wandering Samurai and he
just rolls up into places and uses his
you know his training and his way to
kind of solve the issues and moves on
and that's what this game is it's like
an anthology of stories so broke is
kirsov walk is this Augie ghio Jimbo
impress your friends by telling everyone
actually
this was inspired by Sakia Jimbo also
galaxy brain is that it's a rabbit Ronan
rabbit Ronan yeah his name is Miyamoto
Miyamoto Usagi
instead of Miyamoto Musashi which is
very good very good under fire lone wolf
and cub
that's the one I didn't ask him so I
asked him if he'd seen rurouni kenshin
and he was like yes I have seen Roni
kitchen I was like if there's an easter
egg in there I won't be petting your
folks if you know I was in any way a
lone wolf and cub is another [ __ ] but
like you know everyone felt really
bummed out their questions oh yeah
Joseph Tsushima that'll do man all right
let's move on to listener questions then
if you've got any questions for us you
can email up email us and after dark
podcast at gamespot.com
or you can join our discord and we will
get you in there and we've got a channel
where you can ask whatever questions
you'd like within reason and this week
all the questions come from discord once
again Callie do you want to read the
first one sure switch sure sure
I've had read that on the brain for the
last couple weeks I might download it
again Sandra right dead one playing on
PC was like incredible like it is that's
what my Dunning anyway
this comes from seep have on discord
I've started getting into using nudity
to jump into game design and it's really
hard coming up with an original idea
beyond just doing a 2d platformer I feel
like indie developers 80% of the time
just stick to side-scrolling platformers
with pixel graphics just due to sheer
ease but I feel like the genre and look
up these games are becoming a little
tired are there any common elements of
indie game design that you feel are
overdone and what games of late have
blown away your expectations of what it
indeed about indie developer is capable
of by the way love the podcast I caved
in but yeah kisses zero because you guys
mention it at least once per episode and
I thought they're really digging it we
get it where we a booze thank you pass
on Jake mister I play every JRPG anyway
the first thing that comes to mind for
me is that I personally am tired of like
indeed Metroidvania games i mean i guess
just Metroidvania games in general 2d
ones particularly like ori as beautiful
as those games look by the time the
first one came out I was like I've
played so many indie Metroidvania games
as pretty as this game looks and as
great as it is I just don't know if I
can do that and ever since then I like
still I I find it really difficult to
get into 2d Metroidvania games I think
it's just because like it's such a it's
like so predictable like the art style
really has to draw me in and I guess if
worried didn't draw me in like that it's
got to be something really cool already
- don't worry - and I downloaded it I
want to play yeah I wanted to play it
but it was just like I don't know if I
want to do another I don't I don't know
if I wanna do my Shireen even Hollow
Knight is a game that I've tried to play
so many times because people have told
me it's one of the best games ever like
straight up people have told me it's the
best game ever and like I just I can't
do it cuz I'm just like I don't I don't
want to play a 2-d Metroidvania game I
struggle I mean the difficulties what
got me with all a knight but I feel
similarly about 2d Metroidvania is like
I'm not I don't know I just have maybe a
mental block about it cuz I went through
a phase of playing so many I think the
one exception to the rule is probably
dead cells
yeah well that like shook it up quite a
bit I feel like with the the rogue light
elements and stuff like that but I mean
like one of my favorite games is Super
Metroid and I play that I don't know
every other year or so and I love that
game but I maybe that game for me just
kind of hit that high and and just
nothing is really gotten up there but I
don't know if I don't think that's true
cuz it sounds like Halle Knight like
from what I played I thought the combat
was great it's just like I just lost
theme so fast and I really want to
finish it I just can't do it
mm-hmm the one that I think is like
annoyingly the thing that I am tired of
and the indie game that also recently I
was like this is really good
it's the same thing so like the thing
I'm tired of is the hotline Miami Star
thing or it's like incredibly fast pace
you punch a thing once and instead and
then
if you get killed the you die in one
here and then you got a solid offer
again like it worked but there's just an
abundance of them but then the game that
I really really enjoyed recently I
forgot the name of it was this which one
called
blood roots bloody roots that's the one
I know blood roots I really enjoyed like
it was that but I think after playing
that I was like that was good I don't
think I've enjoyed a game like that
since the original hotline Miami and
kind of hotline Miami - I don't think
all that moment is as good and but I'm
okay with not playing another one of
these for a while yeah yeah that's a
good one - cuz I remember being very
excited for hotline Miami - played
through all of it but by the time I was
done with thinking I was like I don't
need another one of these games for a
while and then I played a pout which I'd
say it's kind of close to that which I
enjoy but once again
yeah like the music is really good the
art style is really good but once again
it was just kind of like I've done this
before which isn't a bad thing right
like I'm sure there are plenty of people
who straight-up missed hotline Miami
never played it and then there's these
other games like blood roots and and a
bout to kind of fill that void so people
can learn about this style but maybe
it's just because I enjoyed hotline
Miami so much and I was like that's it
that's all I need yeah I couldn't get
into a pout and I was surprised because
I look like hotline Miami is one of like
the my top indie games at the very least
I love that game but yet it was kind of
a magic that's hard to recapture I would
say for me the indie thing that I'm kind
of tired of is like Pokemon imitators
and like look I haven't really liked the
3d indeed like I forget my time at
Porsche and I wasn't super into my
Porsche which was like a 3d Harvest Moon
like I think well it's name with that
Pokemon clone that was readable for me
for go existed but I I couldn't get into
tempt I mean part of that time times
fall is not done so
like I can't really say definitively
whether I wouldn't get into some time
but I think when you're going after
rather than a genre but a very specific
kind of game you're gonna run into
issues of people who are into that kind
of game comparing really closely with
the game that they're used to and like
as far as like farm familiars go likes
tardy Valley is probably my favorite
game I've ever played so when you try to
chase that that farm game hi I just like
really don't see anything surpassing
what Staryu valley has done and then
yeah I'm tired of Metroidvania students
hmm 4c path the trick with current indie
games is like take something incredibly
mundane from real life and somehow to
make a call game out of it like the one
I always think of is like this this is
specifically for Lucy remember
supermarket sweep yeah how has no one
turned that into a video game it like a
fun minigame collection
I don't you go check out beep I had an
idea of like a horror game that takes
place in a multiplayer Lobby or not like
it like a like a multiplayer map like
you're just in a multiplayer map and
there's no one there and weed things
start to happen and I mention it on the
podcast
I'm not saying me mentioning it had
anything to do with this but I mentioned
on the podcast like an early hour early
episode and a couple weeks later
jean-luc sent me a link and he's like
hey is this what you were talking about
and sure enough there's a game that was
made like somewhat recently that's just
a horror game where you're in like a
multiplayer Lobby and weird things start
to happen and it's it it was kind of
neat he's core Jake spooky time with
friends for summary yeah who knows it's
actually when I try to get friends to
play with me but they don't join and I
just run around the lobby by myself
horror game where you're in nykeya
and the lights turn off in the IKEA
employees j-school that sounds amazing
you have to do you have to like build
furniture til I escaped them you quick
make a bomb
find it but I really like like just
indie games that take a concept and then
just keep galaxies brain building on it
I mean it becomes a thing yeah yeah the
premise is I was like hey there was that
one game which was like floor is lava
remember that oh the one that was on
Apple arcade yeah yeah so did you ever
play this game like he's gonna this is
gonna sound real weird but I don't know
sticky sticky glue did you ever play
this game so there's this kid in the
playground game we used to play called
sticky sticky glue and what it was like
basically like tag or head so one person
what some people called had tagging like
depending on I moved around a lot of
schools very unstable infancy and it was
different different like things
different names for the games or one of
them was it was tagged one person was it
and then everyone ran and this person
chased them and when they got tagged
instead of being out they would have to
like put their hands out so they were
like told that they were caught in glue
in sticky glue and then what would
happen is another player could then if
they could like run underneath that
person's arm it will put them back in
the game so the person play this yeah
yes we didn't call though so the person
who's tagged listen it's called sickest
thing you do so make the indie games
think you think it Lucy perv but like
I'd love to see like a Rakhi League
style treatment to that you know I'm
saying like it's the arena where you
have to like run around and tag people
and sticky sticky on stick and glue them
before move on to the next question
are there any just quickly are there any
indie games recently that really blew
you away
disco Elysium disco disco
yeah I'd say disco and blood cells blood
cells is what couple years old now but
that's dead cells dead cells like blood
roots and deaths of blood roots net so
and mind
was about disco Elysium hold on there's
that one Apple arcade game that I was
obsessed with what was it Oh grindstone
grindstone yeah yeah yeah happened is
still my favorite apple arcade game it's
just basically doing jigsaw puzzles I
was doing jigsaw puzzles before it was
cool bring back peggle oh yeah next
question is from myron WB since they
seemed everywhere what are your favorite
examples of skill trees and games I
think this is a follow-up to last week
when one of the questions was what do
you want to see not return next-gen in
John Luke was like I'm tired of still
trees in every game sadly for John Luke
Oh sister Seema has two skill trees so I
mean I was gonna say I really liked The
Witcher skill tree it's not like The
Witcher 3 is it's not like you can't
like crafted entirely different
character at that skill tree but it's
really fun matching the colors and
plugging in different cells in order to
like improve your strengths their
alchemy or whatever it might be like
it's really satisfying I think it's just
seeing how all that stuff connects liked
horizon zero dawn tree but I like
couldn't tell you why I just remember
liking it yeah I like skill trees in
general though I'm all about liking I
love skill tree is pretty good yes is
good I don't see 7 remake skill tree no
skill tree Apollo materia I'm with you
nominee the weapon upgrade thing yeah
yeah that's pretty great people and
Final Fantasy 10 Sphere Grid is really
good as well I like that D I like the
way they changed skill trees if you look
across the Mass Effect series and I like
the way in three it was very very simple
but then at one point it just allowed
you to branch and so it's basically like
just a nice way of introducing things
but I think what I what was his skill
tree was it um Far Cry primal I remember
liking their skill tree a lot because I
think of the way that you want
stuff was basically based on what you
collected on how many people you killed
I prefer things like that I prefer like
in Wolfenstein since I was just saying
what was really good cuz it's based on
what you do yeah I really enjoy it when
skills upgrade that way and because it
kind some if I want to unlock everything
it forces me to play in a play style
that I usually wouldn't which i think is
great but it also enforces my it's great
enforcing the way that I like to play
but also encouraging me to try play
cells I don't only do that was one of
the great things about Skyrim to its
skill tree was just it like adapted to
you as opposed to you build the skill
tree or a character at story and you
follow that skill tree it was more like
okay I want to do this play style and
then everything would be tailored to use
you followed that path which is neat and
it's great and I and I liked how that
system was you'd look up at the stars
and you'd see the and you'd like plot
your path myself I thought that was that
was a really neat skill tree just
sometimes pretty good as well yes
straight up banger of the game okay
alright tomorrow read this last question
here oh boy do i we all come in to front
software that's on it does a very boring
start the winner will come in - from
software games and roguelikes expecting
some kind of challenge but what games
over the years have you encountered that
completely caught you off guard with how
hard they were personally I would say
jack - and metlims on the outside they
looks like simple family-friendly
adventures on the inside they're some of
the most unforgiving difficult games of
the ps2 era Jeremy from discord he's in
this code he's not fond and living in
this Court okay you put your hand over
your mouth how did the same by your
voice not exactly says you need to be
there is kind of fire rises Pizza games
look using the outside jack - is a good
is a good one here because I remember
having so much trouble
with that game as a kid like I'd have to
have friends help me be certain areas
because it was so freaking hard I don't
know if it's still hard but I remember
having so much trouble with that game um
I wouldn't say it's a the game in
general but Jesus Christ Sephiroth and
Kingdom Hearts - oh yeah wait you and
Kingdom Hearts two dudes only by Lance
Bass from NSYNC are you kidding oh it is
like the game is from my recollection
and playing it as a kid fairly even in
terms of difficulty and you get to
Sephiroth I think he's an optional boss
anyway but you get to Sephiroth ins like
oh [ __ ] yeah not gonna go the way I want
they were like we need to preserve his
like legacy so make him basically
unbeatable the new collective :
characters trying to fight this evil
here superhero and goofy is just getting
absolutely stomped by a dude was massive
sword constantly like this about have
you done this another one that I can
think of is I had a lot of trouble with
Mario 64 as a kid I thought that game
would be easy cuz it's a Mario game but
I remember especially you get to the
late the later areas because early on
like a lot of the levels make sense
right like you're on you're on a
mountain you're on an icy area and then
I feel like you get to the later levels
and it's just like alright we're just
gonna like vomit a bunch of floating
platforms and you have to jump from
floating platform to floating platform
in order to get this like star that's a
pain in the ass to get while you're
trying to figure out the camera and and
like that game I remember being very
hard I remember not having that much
difficulty with crash bandicoot one
through three as a kid but the remake
was way harder and I was like I remember
I had that with Final Fantasy 9
I remember blog playing Final Fantasy 9
saw me times and then I put it on PSP
was so excited I start playing I was
like how did I play this it's impossible
it's like on I was trying to give to
like the first dungeon and go just out
against stomped what's happening there
was an article going around the other
day where I was like how did anyone beat
The Lion King
as a kid oh yeah come back to it and
it's just nails Mary can like speed run
that thing and I'm like I remember
completing it once it took about half my
life time anyway that's been episode 42
of GameSpot after dark thank you so much
for tuning in and if you have any
questions feel free to email at us email
us I kind of do that email at us do you
mean Britney Spears had a song called
email my heart and there's an incredible
video of her talking about email and
it's like her in the late 90s going well
everyone's on email these days so I'm
saying I'm just saying email my heart
should be the way that we approach
emails with our yes all right well email
our hearts at after dark podcast at
gamespot.com
or if you just want to join the discord
you can message us on Twitter or you can
email us and we'll add you to the
discord server which we have a whole
channel for questions and then plus a
bunch of other stuff movies comics
wrestling TV shows games of course but
please join discord it's great anyway
Kelly where can people find you and you
working on anything this week you can
find me on Twitter at Inc you guys you
go I on KY what about here your flower
guy the flower guide is really coming
together
John Luke has almost finished the
graphics for that to help visualize some
of the more difficult one I'm really I
really am proud of the flower guide of
course credit for the information for a
lot of the information goes to the data
miners Polly's advance flower genetics
guide was a big source and then I
consulted a lot of tests of a lot but I
think what we put together is really
good there you go so if you're curious
about what kind of flowers you can get
or what kind of flowers you want you can
check that out Lucy where can people
find you and
coming up any I think you'll figure that
out they just really into botany these
days yeah yeah Iowa requests I'm at Lucy
James games on to an Instagram what am i
working on I'm working on some episodes
of audio logs that we're doing that I
can't talk about but you should
hopefully see one of those very soon and
we have played for all coming up which
is starts on June 1st so it's kind of
half hour III replacement covering all
the big game announcements previews etc
everything you'd come to expect from us
at e3 and then the other half that I'm
more involved in is the charity stream
so myself to mourn chasity you've been
booking guests in we're gonna have
friends of GameSpot so like people from
the industry be nice um names like Troy
Baker Greg Miller apex legends
voiceovers Assassin's Creed which I
think Sanders
yeah voice actors what did I say
voiceovers voiceovers yeah yeah we've
got like a lot of people the schedule
fellas should be coming out soon
actually we've got we've got hey Zeus
yeah I'm so excited I'm so excited I'm
excited too hey Zeus his toast is the
best and most enjoyable blood-borne
speed runner in the world and I like
gingerly went in I was like please will
you stream for us and he was like oh
hell yeah let's do this I'm like he's
the nicest guy if you watch any of his
like a awesome games done quick stuff
like you will see why he's so good he
like turns his speedruns into their own
narrative and I tells the story it's so
good my favorite bit is his bit about
ladders yeah he's gonna remember yeah
yeah I'm not super into speedrunning
like games done quick never really
interest me but whenever he's on I
typically tune in for that because I
think he's very entertaining and he's
really good at it just watching him yeah
describe as you go like I mean streaming
blood-borne recently is difficult
because talking while playing that game
is hard because you're just so focused
but
is like genuinely funny and entertaining
and I'm very excited for that speaking
which is tomorrow what are you working
on and where can people find you and it
looks like you're frozen you look angry
though well I'm not frozen
oh you froze your facebook just being
really steel but it hold you in a moment
where it was like you were angry okay no
he did it again in the background I'm
trying to see if this it's not this is
gonna be such a weird podcast for those
yes just call it technically different
well you can find two more at two more H
I'm hoping he can come back in to tell
us what he's working on sorry go ahead
I was gonna say check out his go says
sushi my
interview mm-hmm he's helping pulled
together all the games and charged two
guests for play for all scheduled coming
soon be excited again he always does you
can find me at Jacob deck on Twitter and
I have a Witcher video that went up
celebrating five years of that game oh
oh there is celebrating five years that
give and there's no what's going on
oh yes I reviewed I'm doing a review it
should be coming next week I hate this
chord see you next week we plugged all
your stuff for you thank you very much
[Music]